We've come a long way from stealing DVD players
in Los Angeles.
Jason Momoa, an extended family, and a sci-fi
escalation?
Here's what you missed in the Fast X trailer.
The new "Fast X" trailer may clock in at just
under four minutes long, but that's still
more than enough time for Vin Diesel's Dom
and the rest of the crew to wax poetic about
family for a while.
All told, the word "family" is spoken on five
occasions throughout the trailer.
"Family."
"Family"
That's a rate of more than one "family" per
minute, for those keeping track.
All this talk of family especially tracks
with the plot of "Fast X."
The trailer suggests that the 10th mainline
film in the franchise is going to be more
about family than ever.
Dante clearly has it out for Dom on a personal
level, believing the racer to be responsible
for the loss of his family.
As such, it looks like Dom's own family will
be the prime targets of the villain's revenge plot.
One particularly alarming shot of the trailer
sees Dom's son Brian once again getting kidnapped.
"That's the problem with having such a big
family.
How do you choose the ones you save?"
And speaking of Dante, he tends to steal the
show with his outrageous and vindictive behavior.
From the very first moments of his appearance
and voice over, one can tell that this new
antagonist means business.
But it might not be just business that brings
this new character into Dom's life.
It seems as if this Dante character is actually
connected to events from "Fast Five," and
may actually be related to the villain of
that movie, the politician and drug-lord Hernan
Reyes in some form.
Based on some interview comments, it seems
like he might be the son of that past antagonist.
Speaking with Variety, Momoa explained how
much he enjoyed working on "Fast X" and his
time as a villain by saying,
"Time of my life.
I get to be the bad guy finally.
I've been the good guy for a while.
[Dante's] very sadistic and androgynous and
he's a bit of a peacock...
He's got a lot of issues, this guy.
He's definitely got some daddy issues."
In a twist that surprises no one, "Fast X"
adds yet another villain-turned-ally to the
Fast Saga, with John Cena's Jakob Toretto
officially joining the family.
While we only get a brief look at Dom and
Jakob's new relationship, it's worth noting
that Jakob's tone indicates the brothers are
on good terms after making amends at the end
of "F9."
Fans also get a look at Jakob taking on a
group of tactical soldiers.
After combing through the shots of the trailer,
it seems that someone, presumably Dante, sent
the soldiers after Mia and Brian, Dom's son,
but Jakob comes to the rescue.
With Brie Larson and Jason Momoa joining the
"Fast and Furious" franchise, it's easy to
overlook the first appearance of Alan Ritchson
as Agent Rimes.
The trailer shows him getting ready to perform
some tactical shooting, but it's unclear who
his targets are.
Momoa is obviously the Big Bad, but the film's
heroes have been known to rub law enforcement
the wrong way in the past.
Will they get into it with Rimes, or will
he help them stop the bad guys?
If the history of this franchise tells us
anything, it's likely that both scenarios
will happen.
Based on the little glimpse we’ve seen of
Rimes so far, it seems that the character
will fill a Hobbs-type role.
The absence of Dwayne Johnson's no-nonsense
agent has left a void in the franchise that
still hasn't been filled yet, but Ritchson
is a solid choice to lead the next wave of
highly-trained cops into action.
Furthermore, the "Jack Reacher" star is more
than capable of playing a convincing action
hero, so he should feel right at home in this
franchise already.
If there's one thing that's become as consistent
with the "Fast and Furious" franchise as cars
and Coronas, it's old enemies patching things
up and clinking bottles by the end of a heavily
fuelled installment.
Somehow, we managed to move on from the Shaw
brothers, Owen and Deckard, battling against
Dom and his family when they saved his son
in "The Fate of the Furious."
With that said, the air is still in need of
clearing between two of the franchise's most
iconic characters.
Besides playing it safe with plenty of nods
back to previous films, one of the biggest
takeaways is seeing Deckard and Han sharing
the screen.
They may look to be on speaking terms here,
but the chances of them getting in a scrap
to let off some long overdue steam beforehand
has to happen, right?
The people have waited too long for justice
for Han, and now we might be getting it.
For a saga that has never once attempted to
hide its most bonkers story choices, the tale
of Toretto has done the unthinkable in the
final moments of this new trailer — it actually
has stumped us over what's going on between
Letty and Cipher.
If Dom playing tug of war with some helicopters
had our jaws dropping, seeing the long-time
villain wake up with Dominic's sweetheart
has us scratching our chins and reaching a
shocking theory.
Are they...are they about to do a body swap?
It's become an unwritten rule after "Fast
Five" that anything could happen in this science-defying series.
We thought it reached a limit for a franchise
that has sent two of its characters to space
in a clapped-out Pontiac Fiero, as well as
revealing our leading man had a brother he
didn't mention for nine films.
And yet, something about those final few seconds
screams, "Face/Off," with both characters
appearing like they're looking in a mirror,
only...not.
Is this really what's happening?
Or is this theory simply…
Ludacris?
"Maybe.
Or maybe you're just a dumba**."
We can only wait and see.